bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour cette critique de la vie sur notre
planète la nouvelle série Netflix avec
des dinosaures dedans qui a beaucoup
suscité de hype y compris pour moi
notamment parce que elle est produite
par Steven Spielberg le réalisateur le
fameux réalisateur d'Aviator et de Ready
Player One et cette série en fait c'est
une série qui divise c'est une série qui
divise parce que il y a ceux qui voient
en elle la digne successeur de
préhistorique planet et de sur la terre
des dinosaures donc c'est c'est un
docufiction hein donc on compare les
docufictions aux autres docufictions et
il y a ceux qui voient en elle le le
diable c'est non c'est une oui c'est une
série qui dit beaucoup de conneries
aussi voilà puis il y a des gens qui ont
quand même pas hésité à pointer du doigt
certaines choses qui étaient dites
là-dedans et qui étaient franchement pas
fille folle voilà donc qu'est-ce qu'il
faut en penser de cette série pré pas
préhistorique planète justement la vie
sur notre planète quoi en penser bien je
vous propose mon avis euh un avis que je
vais diviser en deux parties donc
d'abord un avis général avec les bons et
les mauvais points puis ensuite on fera
épisode par épisode les choses qui m'ont
le plus marqué alors je vais pas
forcément faire un je vais pas forcément
décortiquer chaque épisode un par un je
vais prendre les choses qui m'ont le
plus marqué dans chaque épisode j'ai
beaucoup de choses à dire sur l'épisode
3 ceci étant dit donc faites
immédiatement la paix avec l'idée que
cette deuxième partie de vidéo ça va
être long donc si vous voulez un avis
rapide la vie rapide c'est le début de
la vidéo c'est les 20 premières minutes
alors est-ce que je recommande la vie
sur notre planète la réponse est bah si
les docu fiction c'est votre cam et que
vous avez donc fait la paix avec l'idée
que de toute façon vous n'apprendrez pas
grand-chose en les regardant et bien oui
allez voir la vie sur notre planète par
contre il va falloir que je vous
préviennent à l'avance la vie sur notre
planète c'est pas un documentaire sur
les dinosaures il y a même pas tant de
fossiles que ça en réalité la vie sur
notre planète c'est un documentaire
animalier avec des espèces éteintes à
l'intérieur voilà en guest en en invité
surprise des espèces éteintes à
l'intérieur il y a vraiment pas beaucoup
de de segments qui sont dédiés on va
dire à qui sont dédiés bah aux espèces
éteintes de manière générale et encore
moins au dinosaures puisque c'est un
documentaire qui essaie quand même de
faire la Parbelle à d'autres espèces que
les dinosaures donc ça c'est un des très
bons points dont je vais discuter dans
une minute mais c'est un documentaire
qui essaie quand même de faire la
Parbelle à d'autres choses justement que
les dinosaures donc il y a basiquement
un tiers des épisodes seulement qui est
réellement consacré au au dinosaures en
tout cas à la période
Mésozoïque et sur ce tiers d'épisode il
y a même pas la moitié voire même un/ers
voire même moins que ça il y a vraiment
très peu de segment en fait où vous
allez voir du dinosaure à l'intérieur
donc si vous vous attendez en regardant
la vie sur notre planète avoir un
documentaire sur les dinosaures
attendez-vous à être déçu parce queil y
aura pas tant que ça il y a pas mal de
paléontologie dedans mais ça reste quand
même du jus de documentaire animalier
saupoudré de d'espèces éteintes et pas
le et pas l'inverse c'est pas c'est pas
ça donc oui si les docu fiction ça vous
intéresse oui si les documentaires
animaliers ça vous intéresse oui allez
voir la vie sur notre planète c'est pas
mauvais contrairement à ce que les
documentaire Netflix récemment ont pu
faire naître comme réputation hein je
pense à Cléopâtre par exemple tous les
documentaires Netflix ne sont pas ne
sont pas des des catastrophes
industrielles celui-là il est très bien
ça va il s'en sort donc oui je pense que
globalement dans dans une générale dans
une optique générale je recommanderit la
vie sur notre planète en sachant ce que
vous allez voir à savoir pas grand
membre dinosaure et pas beaucoup
d'information pas beaucoup
d'informations de choses que vous
apprendrez vous apprendrez pas
grand-chose je pense en regardant la vie
sur notre planète en tout cas vous
n'apprendrez pas grand-chose sur les
fossiles peut-être sur les espèces
modernes mais pas sur les espèces
fossiles donc maintenant les choses qui
sont bonnes dans la vie sur notre
planète qu'est-ce qui va bien dans la
vie sur notre planète c'est beau
on on en attend pas moins d'ailleurs de
de quand on a comme producteur le
réalisateur de
Aviator et de La Liste de Schindler on
en attend pas moins d'avoir un bon
documentaire donc c'est un c'est c'est
c'est beau c'est à la fois beau c'est
bien réalisé il y a des beaux il y a des
beaux panoramiques des paysages
splendide les CGI sont pas trop
dégueulasses donc les CGI les effets
numériques donc les reconstructions de
des espèces éteintes sont pas dégueux à
part pour les mammifères euh il y a
certains mammifères enfin les deux
derniers épisodes he globalement les
deux derniers épisodes c'est le gros
point noir on en parlera mais c'est
vraiment les gros points noirs où
vraiment il y a quasiment plus d'espèces
éteintes en fait dans les deux derniers
épisodes et et et les modélisations sont
vraiment pas ouf donc à part pour les
deux derniers épisodes c'est beau pareil
la musique la musique est très belle
c'est de la musique orchestrale c'est
une musique de film ça a été composé
c'est original c'est
machin si vous bingjwz la vie sur notre
planète
le thème principal va commencer par vous
courir sur le haricot je je vous annonce
immédiatement que il y a une abondance
il y a un thème
principal dans la vie sur notre planète
et ce thème principal tourne en boucle
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup tentez si
bien que si vous regardez un épisode par
jour ça va mais alors si vous regardez
live enfin si vous regardez la vie sur
notre planète tout d'un coup bingj
watchat c'est ça finit par vous voilà ça
finit par vous prendre end les neurones
mais sinon ouais la musique est très
belle très bon point pour la vie sur
notre planète bah on nous montre pas que
des dinos et ça c'est bien c'était un
gros mauvais point d'ailleurs de c'était
un très très gros mauvais point dans
préhistoric planè saison 1 et saison 2
non seulement on nous montrait que des
trucs du crétac enfin non seulement on
nous montrait quasiment que des
dinosaures avec une saoudrée de pérosaur
et de reptiles marin mais en plus on se
contentait du CR Crétacé terminal
c'était même pas genre juste le Crétacé
c'est pas le Crétacé supérieur c'est une
tranche de temps d'une poignée de de
centaines de milliers d'années on se
contentait du Crétacé terminal donc la
diversité c'était voilà ce qui était le
gros problème de préhistorique planète
donc là on est revenu sur une
philosophie plus proche de celle de sur
la terre des dinosaures avec du coup une
vraie diversité même même mieux que sur
la terre des dinosaures dans le sens où
là on va vraiment explorer toute
l'histoire de la vie il y a vraiment un
épisode par chapitre entre guillemets de
l'histoire de la vie épisode 1 bon c'est
une vue générale épisode 2 c'est la vie
dans les océans avant le milieu du
Paléozoïque c'est-à-dire avant que les
tétrapodes commencent à à marcher sur
terre ensuite vous avez les premiers
tétrapodes dans l'épisode 3 vous avez
euh les épisodes 4 et 5 qui normalement
sont consacrés au mésozoïqu de manière
générale euh ça inclut les dinosaures
mais pas queux vous avez euh l'épisode 6
euh qui est aussi sur les dinosaures et
sur le sur la l'extinction à la fin du
temps des dinosaures et vous avez
l'épisode 7 et 8 les épisodes 7 et 8 qui
sont consacrés exclusivement aux
mammifères et aux oiseaux avec l'épisode
8 qui est vraiment consacré
exclusivement aux oiseaux donc donc
voilà c'est c'est c'est vraiment une
gradation en fait si vous voulez au
niveau de l'organisation qui est assez
claire assez facile à suivre c'est assez
évident ce qu'ils ont essayé de faire et
du coup il y a plein de diversité
là-dedans vu qu'on couvre une grande
quantité de temps il y a plein de
diversité là-dedans donc on va voir des
diversités de comportement on va voir
une diversité animale après voilà faut
tempérer ça aussi ce qu'on voit ça reste
du grand classique hein on reste sur de
l'hémisphère Nord bien bien tassé hein à
part quand on nous parle des mastupio en
Australie et et un petit peu des des
oiseaux terreur en Amérique du Sud mais
on reste sur une faune globalement
nord-américaine étendue hémisphère nord
donc on reste dans la zone de confort
hein on va pas non plus trop bousculer
le chalent
euh mais au moins ça a au moins le
mérite voilà de pas que nous parler des
dinosaures mais bon vous retrouverez les
grands classiques hein les mamouths les
smilodons les les
dcléostéus il y a il y a pas un
mégalodon mais ils nous ont rentré un
truc qui ressemble à suffisamment enfin
ils ont ce qu'on appelle ce qu'on
appellerait vraiment du du forçage au
forcep par quoi c'est ils nous ont forcé
un un truc qui ressemble à un mégalodon
le plus possible euh dans l'épisode sur
les les mammifères l'épisode 7 je crois
bref ils ont ils nous ont ramené des
grands classiques quoi c'est pas non
plus vous allez pas vous sentir très
très très dépayisé si vous si vous êtes
déjà un paléogek et vous avez déjà le
kit de base arc voilà en gros si vous
avez déjà le kit de base du paléog Geek
vous allez pas vous sentir très dépayisé
et comme je disais moi au bout d'un
moment enfin comme ça devenait vraiment
vraiment trop prévisible j'ai fini par
m'ennuyer au bout du 56e épisode
d'autant que les épisodes 7 et 8 sont
vraiment laborieux en terme de de
narration comme je disais on en
reparlera mais bref c'est il y a de la
diversité et ça c'est un bon point donc
diversité au niveau des comportements
c'est pas comme préhistoric planète où
on a littéralement que des parades
nuptiales et ça commence à voilà au bout
d'un moment vous parade nupial et là
pouf par nupial et là paf parade nupial
et là pouf comportement de comportement
en meut
oh là au moins il y a de la vraie
diversité voilà il y a des des chasseurs
solitaires il y a des charogniards il y
a des il y a des prédateurs il y a des
herbivores il y a des il y a des de la
protection de territoire il y a des des
parades sexuels aussi il y en a il y pas
que ça mais il y en a mais voilà il y a
il y a de la diversité euh on nous
rappelle sans cesse qu'il n'y a pas que
les dinosaures dans la vie donc comme je
disais il y a de la diversité mais même
les épisodes qui sont consacrés aux
dinosaures ne sont pas consacrés
uniquement qu'au dinosaures et ça c'est
vachement bien donc il y a il y a quand
même un chapitre où d'ailleurs on se
demande même ce qu'il fout à ce
moment-là c'est on nous parle de
dinosaur et pouf d'un seul coup les
termites pourquoi pourquoi on nous parle
de termite oui on vous rappelle que il y
a autre chose que les dinosaures et oui
le Mésozoïque c'est certes connu comme
étant l'air des dinosaures mais il y a
pas que les dinosaures et moi je pense
que c'est à mettre à leur crédit alors
c'est un peu perturbant quand ça arrive
parce que tu te dis mais je m'en fous
montre-moi des dinosaures mais c'est un
peu perturbant au moment où ça arrive
mais globalement c'est c'est bienvenu
parce que quand on y réfléchit c'est
vrai que il faut nous montrer tous ces
insectes ces invertébrés ces autres
reptiles qui vivaient à la même époque
que les dinosaures un tout petit peu de
mammifèr point trop nenfo les mammifères
ils ont pas vraiment insisté dessus
enfin les mammifères qui vivaient à
l'époque des dinosaures j'entends ils
ont pas trop insisté dessus ni les
oiseaux d'ailleurs mais il faut rendre à
César ce qui est à César quand il s'agit
de nous rappeler que il y a des corau
qui a des crustacés qu' y a d'autres
animaux qui vivaient à la même époque
ils le font et ça c'est bien ça c'est
bien par voilà on on aurait tendance à à
vouloir focuser uniquement sur le groupe
d'intérêt vous savez euh mais non eux
ils font quand même cette démarche ils
ont quand même cette démarche de vouloir
nous montrer un écosystème alors pas
entier non plus mais de vouloir nous
montrer un écosystème et puis pour finir
sur les bons points il y a évidemment
les les choses qu'il y a dedans je vais
revenir évidemment je vais détailler
tout ça quand on fera épisode par
épisode mais si vous voulez savoir il y
a des très bonnes choses la biologie des
orthoscèes ça m'a ça m'a beaucoup plu
euh la parade la parade pour
impressionner les rivaux pas la parade
nuptiale justement mais la parade pour
impressionner les rivaux des Forus
racidés je trouvais ça pas mal la parade
nuptiale des T-Rex
ça voilà voilà ça c'est ce que je
voulais voir dans préhistorique planè la
parade nuptiale des Trex elle est
parfaite euh et les la scène des
glyptodontes et là je je suis sûr si
vous avez vu vous vous voyez quelle
scène je veux dire c'est la scène culte
de la série la scène des
glyptodontes bon surtout parce qu'elle
arrive au milieu d'un épisode très
chiant je trouve mais c'est la scène des
gptodonte c'est c'était du caviar j'ai
trouvé ça très drôle on a trouvé ça très
drôle avec Miss plume donc voilà ça
c'est pour la liste des choses qui vont
bien donc c'est très beau c'est très
bien la musique est très bonne il y a de
la belle diversité à l'intérieur de la
diversité de comportement de la
diversité des espèces on oublie pas les
invertébrés et ça c'est bien et on nous
montre des choses qui sont quand même
originales nouvelles des choses qu'on n
pas vu ailleurs voilà ou qu'on aurait
voulu voir ailleurs mais qui n'ont pas
été faites ailleurs maintenant il y a
les mauvais points et je pense que le
premier mauvais point c'est bah c'est un
mauvais point que que de toute façon je
propose à chaque nouveau docu fiction
c'est quoiqu qu'on apprend en regardant
ce truc et la réponse dans les
docufictions c'est qu'on apprend rien de
toute façon parce que les docufictions
bah le problème c'est que c'est du
documentaire et de la fiction donc tu
sais jamais où où commence le
documentaire et où s'arrête la fiction
et généralement on est plus sur un ratio
90 % de fiction 10 documentaire 10 % de
de de de vraies données scientifiques
qui ont été inclues mais comme de toute
façon vous n'avez aucun moyen de savoir
où sont ces 10 % dans le truc bah vous
n'apprenez rien donc ou autant ne rien
apprendre au risque d'apprendre des
conneries parce que 90 % est inventé et
certaines c'est des grosses conneries
c'est là le problème qu'il y a eu avec
la vie sur notre planète c'est que il y
a certaines choses qui sont dites dans
ce documentaire qui sont euh qui sont
qui sont pas que des grosses
approximations c'est c'est au-delà de la
grosse approximation on est au-delà de
la simplification on est vraiment durant
de la connerie voilà on est dur rant de
de vraiment vous a on vous raconte
n'importe quoi et mon préféré mon favori
mon chouchou et ils ne l'ont pas on n'y
a pas coupé c'est évidemment les Raptors
qui chassent en meut mais oui mais bien
sûr on en parlera on en parlera des
raptur qui chasse en meut pour la
version courte pour la revue courte je
ne vais pas en parler je vais pas
développp ça maintenant mais sachez
qu'il y a une vidéo dans les com enfin
dans la section description sous cette
sous cette vidéoci il y a un lien vers
une autre vidéo que j'ai faite où
pendant une heure et demi je débunk
cette idée que il y a les Raptors il
chassé en meut voilà il y a une pile de
preuves pour dire que les Raptors
chassai pas en meut qu'on a accumulé au
fil des années et il faudrait il serait
peut-être temps de lâcher la grappe
maintenant bon bref donc mais je je
parle de ça mais il y a plein d'autres
il y a plein d'autres conneries les
trilobites étaient les premiers
arthropodes c'est pas vrai surtout
que surtout que le trilobit qui nous
montre c'est pas non plus le
trilobit le plus vieux du monde donc
genre les trilobit étaient les premiers
arthropodes les
les le festival le le festival des
clichés sur les fossil vivant hein on
ils y ont tous droit ils sont tous là
les crocos les notiloï
les limules non je crois pas qu'il y a
les limules mais bref il y a ils sont
tous là les fossiles vivants ils sont là
ils sont bien on on y coupe pas donc les
requins fossils vivants les dès le début
genre dès l'épisode 1 dans les 20
premières minutes voilà les requins ils
sont catalogués fossiles vivant il a
gagné pas voilà donc ça c'est des
conneries c'est c'est tout c'est pas des
approximations c'est pas des
simplifications c'est des conneries mais
il y a effectivement aussi c'est NOTAM
l'épisode 1 l'épisode 1 qui essae qui
est une bande annonce en fait de de tous
les épisodes de la série l'épisode 1
c'est une bande annonce de la série de
50 minutes enin c'est une bande annonce
de 50 minutes de toute la série et et ça
va vite du coup parce que ça vraiment ça
couvre tout de l'origine de la vie à la
fin du Cénozoïque donc on doit recouvrir
4 milliards d'années de de d'évolution
de la vie en 50 minutes avec un
commentaire toutes les toutes les 3
minutes he parce que c'est une c'est
contemplatif du coup hein donc c'est
joli c'est joli mais du coup c'est
contemplatif et du coup il y a pas
beaucoup de c'est pas enfin il y a
beaucoup de commentaires comparé à
préhistorique planè mais ça reste quand
même assez lent donc il y a pas beaucoup
de place pour raconter des choses donc
bah on simplifie on simplifie à très
gros
trait
et encore une fois l'idée étant que la
simplification c'est pas grave
simplifier dans un documentaire ce n'est
pas grave ton corps ch change non c'est
pas ça simplifier dans un documentaire
ce n'est pas grave mais la question est
de savoir pourquoi quel est le message
que vous essayez de faire passer et je
pense qu'un des plus gros problèmes avec
la vie sur notre planète c'est qu'il y a
pas vraiment de message je crois pas
qu'ils aient qu'ils aient essayer
d'accomplir autre chose que de surfer
sur la vague de préhistorique
planète bah ça se voit déjà par la
qualité graphique des reconstructions
des Paléo reconstruction notamment des
dinosaures euh
encore une fois la qualité graphique
esthétique est sublime au niveau des
dinosaures je j'insiste sur au niveau
des dinosaures puisque je le répète les
mammifères c'était pas ouf
mais il y a une volonté donc de surfer
sur préhistorique planète mais du coup
au détriment de
l'écriture donc pourquoi quel est quel
est le message qu'ils essayent de faire
passer dans la vie sur notre planète on
sait pas trop mais en tout cas ils
essayent un peu de singer préhistorique
planète et un un peu sur la terre des
dinosaures aussi et du coup il y a pas
de message et du coup la raison de cette
sursimplification bah encore une fois
c'est ne pas bousculer l'auditoire c'est
la seule raison de cette
sursimplification donc on a un peu des
simplifications un peu au pif en fait on
a des simplifications qui vont un peu au
pif et parfois on a juste du name
dropping au niveau des dinosaures qui
sont qui sont assez maladroit on nous
balance un nom comme ça voilà et vous
êtes censé le connaître et sinon bah
vous dire voir sur google si vous
arrivez à comprendre ce que Morgan
Freeman dit parce que moi je l'ai vu en
VO du coup hein comme indiqué par C ce
screenshot que je vous
affiche moi je l'ai vu en VO et quand
vous le voyez en VO la voix de Morgan
Freeman bah il fait un concours avec
David àamboro pour savoir lequel des
deux est le plus fatigué et c'est normal
ils ont 90 piges et quelques foutez-leur
la paix c'est c'est pas contre Morgan
Freeman que je dis ça Morgan Freeman il
est très bien dans les années 90 il
faisait des documentaires enfin il
faisait des des commentaires sur
documentaire il a une voix il a voilà il
a ce qu'il faut mais il a 90 ans
maintenant enfin je sais plus non 86 un
truc comme ça mais
bref lui et David atamborau ils ont 90
piges et tu leur fais encore commenter
des documentaires et autant David
àomboro ils avaient quand même fait en
sorte qu'il ait pas trop de voix off sur
préhistorique planè autant dans la vie
sur notre planète enfin life on her
Planet du coup la version originale on
l'entend tout le temps et ils l'ont fait
beaucoup parler et il y a vraiment des
fois où tu l'entends qu'il a la bouche
pâteuse c'est il a il est bon bah voilà
il est fatigué que voulez-vous il est
fatigué et enregistré vous imaginez il y
a huit épisode de 1 heure chacun
imaginez le temps que le mec a dû passer
en
studio bref donc si vous arrivez à
comprendre ce que Morgan Freeman dit et
c'est pas forcément gagné vous pourrez
éventuellement aller googler les espèces
don dont ils ont parlé le moment où il a
parlé de de c'est quoi Camero seras
Camero seras qui est l'orthocer géant
dans l'épisode 2 Camero seras j'avais
pas compris je vous avoue que sur le
coup
camer what the what donc ouais ça aussi
ça fait partie des mauvais points c'est
prenez des gens prenez des gens enfin
prenez des comédiens doublage jeunes je
pense que Morgan Freeman c'est c'est bon
sa retraite elle est prête il est fait
il il a il a du pognon il s'en sortira
sans ça tu vois prenez prenez des
comédiens de doublage jeun frais vivace
et qui ont besoin d'argent pour faire
les commentaires et qui ont certainement
une voix toute aussi même même si vous
voulez prenez un imitateur de Morgan
Freeman mais un imitateur de Morgan
Freeman jeune parce que là c'est c'est
c'est compliqué à écouter en fait et
c'est c'est bien le problème c'est que
vous avez des commentaires du coup tout
le long du documentaire et c'est
compliqué à écouter parce que ouis ouais
qu'est-ce qu'il a dit là il y a vraiment
des phrases où je me suis dit mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a dit là donc voilà il y
a tous ces clichés pour en revenir au
problème il y a toutes tous ces clichés
sur les espèces éteintes ça vous allez
pas y couper il y a tous ces clichés sur
les fossiles vivants il y a pas mal de
clichés aussi sur les espèces modernes
toujours dans la catégorie allez-vous
apprendre quelque chose en le regardant
il y a des clichés sur les espèces
modernes qui vont au-delà de juste les
crocos les les requins et les notiles
c'est des fossiles vivants il y a par
exemple le passage avec les gnous on
nous montre des gnous en train de boire
passage qui est d'ailleurs complètement
repompé sur un documentaire de que
j'avais déjà vu he de la BBC et
d'ailleurs parlons-en avant avant que je
parle de mesnou mais
parlons-en c'est ces passages où je
disais c'est à moitié docum enfin c'est
même pas à moitié c'est 2 tiers au moins
2/ers documentaire animalier un/ers
documentaire sur la vie sur les fossiles
c'est 2 tiers de documentaire animalier
il y a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
ressuscès d'autres documentaires
principalement de la BBC je suspecte
qu'ils ont dû racheter des trucs à
national géographique mais j'en sais
rien je suis pas allé vérifier mais
ouais il y a de la ressucée de
documentaire que vous aurez déjà vu donc
notamment ce passage sur les gnou mais
il y a le passage sur les flamants roses
aussi les les Flamans roses qui marchent
et puis qui font la parade en tournant
la tête là qu'on avait repris dans
nous-même dans une vidéo comique mais
pour en faire un passage comique mais
c'est c'est des trucs qu'on a déjà vu
ailleurs en fait et ils sont allés
racheter finalement ils sont allés
charognier des des morceaux de
documentaire ailleurs
et ça ça va aussi un peu dans le sens du
on a essayé d'assembler un documentaire
vite fait pour faire comme préhistoric
planè mais moins
cher comme ça on a pu mettre plus
d'énergie et d'argent dans les
modélisations 3D parce que du coup on a
déjà les les images pour les espèces
modernes donc ouais il y a ça ça peut
être un problème ça peut être un
problème enfin on peut considérer ça
comme un problème mais donc mnou m gnou
on les voit boire dans une rivière
infesté de crocodile et le commentateur
donc Morgan FremAN nous dit les gnous
sont oblivious to the danger ils sont il
ils n'ont aucune conscience du danger et
ça c'est un c'est un cliché de
documentaire c'est un cliché de
documentaire de de voir des animaux
boire dans une rivière et dire et
entendre le commentateur dire ils sont
ils sont inconscients du danger mais si
les gnou les gnou qui
boivent dans les rivières pendant leur
grande migration ont totalement et
complètement pleinement et sans aucune
hésitation conscience qu'elle est
infestée de crocodile cette rivière
c'est juste qu'ils sont en pleine
migration et ils ont la
soif ils ont la soif ils n'ont
pas le choix soit ils boivent soit ils
crèvent donc s'ils vont tous boire en
même temps bon ben il y a 10 crocodiles
ou il y a une centaine de crocodile pour
10000 gnou bon bah tant pis pour eux
tant pis pour ceux qui se feront choper
tu vois mais
c'est c'est dire que les gnous ne sont
pas conscients du danger c'est une
énorme connerie c'est un cliché de
documentaire Les il y a la quantité
d'animaux qui grognent par exemple ça
parlons-en parlons-en des espèces
modernes les sèches qui grognent les
poissons qui
grognent les fourmis il y a une charge
de fourmis dans l'un des épisodes c'est
intéressant hein de nous montrer une
guerre entre les fourmis et les termites
il y a une charge de fourmis contre des
termites les fourmis poussent un cri de
guerre je vous jure que c'est vrai je
vous jure que c'est vrai donc oui
allez-vous apprendre des choses c'est
plus probable que non mais normalement
vous passerez pas un trop mauvais moment
il y a un autre problème euh dans une
autre catégorie un autre une autre
catégorie de problème c'est euh
l'écriture c'est un documentaire qui a
pas été super bien écrit je trouve euh
notamment beaucoup de répétitions bah et
encore une fois je je le mets sur le
compte de ils ont voulu très très vite
faire un documentaire qui allait euh
rapidement surfer sur la vague euh
préhistorique planète euh donc ils ont
très très rapidement écrit un un script
et ça se voit ça se voit il y a
notamment un script qui souffre
d'énormément de répétitions donc encore
une fois dans la version originale
peut-être que ça a été corrigé dans la
version française peut-être que ils ont
fait un PEL à un vocabulaire plus varié
dans la version française mais il y a
pas un seul épisode où le mot thrive
donc prospérer hein quand les espè les
espèces prospèrent il y a pas un seul
épisode où le mot thrive n'est pas dit
au moins deux voire trois fois les
choses ont changé pour t changer pour
toujours pareil quasiment dans tous les
épisodes vous y avez le
droit les choses à partir de là les
choses ne seront plus jamais les
mêmes pareil quasiment dans tous les
épisodes vous l'avez et alors le like
never before like never before comme
jamais
auparavant là c'est c'est un bingo faut
pas faire un jeu à boire avec like never
before sur la vie sur notre planète vous
vous allez il va vous
coucher vont vous coucher net faites pas
un jeu à boire sur like never before
donc ouais c'est donc il y a des il y a
ces répétitions qui sont pas ouf et et
c'est tout lié en fait au au visuel
c'est-à-dire que ils avaient des idées
visuellement et ça se voit il ils ont
voulu proposer des choses visuellement
mais par contre ils ont pas du tout
réfléchi à au reste quoi donc on va en
parler he ça des des idées du visuel ils
avaient une idée du Cool ils avaient des
choses cool qu'il voulaient montrer et
et c'est souvent des choses cool et ça
se voit parce que c'est des choses cool
qui marchent pas du tout il y a des
choses cool qu'ils ont montré qui
marchent très bien hein le l'orthocè les
forusracides les Trex les glyptodontes
j'en ai déjà parlé dans la dans la
section précédente mais il y a des
choses cool qui marcheent pas du tout et
qui vous et qui vous font voir du coup
les ficelles derrière en fait et les
ficelles c'est ah oui on voulait
absolument montrer ça mais ça marche pas
et je pense que c'est ça en fait c'est
que ils ont un scénario qui amène à des
choses
comme la crise la crise KPG la crise
l'extinction de la fin des dinosaures
c'est un truc cool visuellement mais ce
qui est raconté à ce
moment-là on en parlera dans le détail
des épisodes ce qui est raconté à ce
moment là on sent bien qu'il savait pas
quoi dire et puis pour finir sur les
points
négatifs le la chronologie c'est un
documentaire qui fait donc de fait de ce
côté un peu bâtard entre documentaire
animalier et documentaires sur les
espèces éteintes ils ont essayé comme je
le disais de de suivre une chronologie
où on va de l'origine de la vie le
Paléozoïque le Mésozoïque le Cénozoïque
ils ont essayé de suivre cette
chronologie là mais en faisant sans
cesse des allers-retours entre le passé
et le et le présent et pas genre des all
pas il y a pas genre un aller-retour par
épisode entre le passé et le présent où
il y a pas genre une seule époque qui
qui est comparé au présent à chaque fois
non non il ils font des mouvements de
fou de millions d'années de centaines de
millions d'années dans le passé dans
chaque
épisode et à chaque fois il pigpong ça
avec une comparaison avec le présent
alors l'idée est cool en soit l'idée est
cool c'est-à-dire qu'on vous montre un
truc qui se passait par le passé on vous
montre un truc comparable dans le
présent des fois la comparaison est un
un peu chaude à suivre hein je confère
ma remarque sur les termites des fois on
vous montre un comportement social chez
un dinosaur denonicus qui chasse en meut
hein en l'occurrence et on vous dit en
parlant de comportement social les
termites et là on vous montre les
termite et donc des fois le pingpong il
coule pas de source quoi c'est ça il est
dur à suivre et moi qui suis à l'aise
avec le le les temps
géologique ça va j'ai réussi à suivre il
y a aucun problème enfin même à des
moments quand même je me suis retrouvé
paumé de dans l'épisode 1 quand j'avais
pas encore compris que c'était ça qu'ils
allaient faire ou l'épisode 2 je sais
plus enfin un moment au début de la
série en fait où c'était pas encore très
clair qu'ils allaient faire justement ce
système de ping-pong je me suis demandé
mais c sèche là c'est une sèche éteinte
qu'ils ont refait en CGI ou c'est une
sèche moderne c'est c'est quoi ça bon
ceci dit c'est à mettre à leur crédit je
m'attendais à ce que ce soit tellement
bien fait que j'ai pris une sèche
moderne pour une sèche en CGI donc c'est
c'est aussi à mettre à leur crédit mais
du coup il y a il y a cette il y a a il
y a ce ping-pong constant entre le passé
et le présent avec en plus des époques
différentes dans le passé et alors
quelqu'un qui connaît pas les temps
géologiques enfin vous me direz hein si
vous êtes justement pas familier avec
l'étant géologique et que vous avez vu
la série jusqu'à quel point c'était
horrible à suivre mais à mon avis
c'était pas agréable à la fin c'est
limite frustrant en fait parce que c'est
vraiment euh c'est c'est bah comme je
disais des fois
des fois il y a aucun rapport quoi entre
les denonicus et les termites et des
fois c'est juste ouais quand est-ce que
tu nous montres des fossils quoi est-ce
que est-ce que vous comptez avoir des
dinosaures dans votre documentaire sur
les dinosaures hein eo
eo c'était un peu ça au bout d'un moment
donc donc ouais je l'ai plutôt mis dans
les points négatifs ça parce que même si
c'est original et que et que je vois ce
qu'ils ont essayé de faire et que c'est
ce qui se ressemble plus à un message on
va dire dans le dans le le film c'est
c'est c'est intéressant parce que c'est
le principe d'actualisme en fait que ça
illustre c'est pas un film c'est une
série documentaire mais c'est c'est
intéressant parce que ça illustre
justement le principe d'actualisme qui
n'est pourtant pas au cœur de la
démarche de ce documentaire mais malgré
soi en fait ça illustre le principe
d'actualisme qui est au cœur de la
démarche scientifique de la démarche
paléontologique il faut savoir ce qui se
passe chez les espèces modernes pour
comprendre ce que faisaient les espèces
du passé voilà là on a fini la vie
générale donc je le répète est-ce que je
recommande le visionnage oui mais vous
apprendrez pas grand-chose ou vous
apprendrez assez peu de choses c'est
agréable c'est c'est c'est pas vilain du
tout c'est même plutôt beau à regarder
personnellement j'ai fini par trouver le
temps long mais j'aurais peut-être pas
dû le bingjw non plus c'est c'est ma
faute mais en même temps voilà Netflix
et binge watching c'est un peu le c'est
c'est ça voilà c'est eux qui ont inventé
ça quoi donc bon donc vous pouvez je
vous recommande je pense je peux dire je
vous recommande la vie sur notre planète
avec cette cette petite cette petite
astérisque que c'est un docufiction et
que donc vous vous n'en apprendrez pas
plus en regardant ce docu fiction que
n'importe quel autre docu fiction on va
pouvoir passer maintenant à la revue
individuel de chaque épisode alors déjà
je vais pas faire l'épisode 1 parce que
j'ai déjà dit tout ce que j'avais à dire
sur l'épisode 1 c'est un c'est une bande
annonce pour les autres épisodes donc
oui il y a plein de conneries qui sont
dites à l'intérieur il y a des énnormes
raccourcis qui sont fait à l'intérieur
mais en même temps voilà qu'est-ce que
tu veux faire de résumer toute
l'histoire de la vie en 50 minutes si si
moi pour un cours je devais résumer
toute l'histoire de la vie en 50 minutes
à des gens en partant du principe que
l'audience à laquelle je parle n'est pas
spécialement éduquée à la vie sur notre
planète donc à l'évolution de la vie sur
notre
planète donc basiquement des premières
années en géologie par
exemple
je sais pas si je ferai beaucoup mieux
donc à part à part en répétant sans
cesse alors je vous dis ça mais en même
temps je simplifie tu vois ce qui n'est
pas ce qui ce qui au niveau de
l'écriture serait catastrophique hein on
est bien d'accord à part répéter sans
cesse je
simplifie tu peux pas vraiment t'en
sortir donc j'ai j'ai assez rapidement
pardonné à l'épisode 1 d'être ce qu'il
est on passe à l'épisode 2 donc
l'épisode 2 il couvre aussi beaucoup
beaucoup de terrain hein il couvre
l'évolution des des invertébrés avant
l'arrivée des tétrapodes sur la terre
ferme donc toute la basiquement tout le
la moitié inférieure du
Paléozoïque c'est donc un épisode qui
lui aussi va nous balancer son lot de
banalité hein de de banalités et de
cliché mais au milieu de toutes ces
banalités et de ces clichés sur les
orthosères les trilobites les coros et
cetera il y a quand même des choses
intéressantes et notamment cet orthosère
enfin la la façon dont il représente les
orthosèes en train de chasser alors
évidemment l'orthoscère qu'ils ont
représenté c'est un orthosère géant
évidemment on va pas vous représenter
des orthocer de taille normale mais on
vous présente un orthocer géant et ces
orthocerres géants en fait ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant dans leur dans la façon
dont ils sont représentés bah c'est
qu'en fait ils utilisent leur coquilles
qui était donc probablement rempli de
gaz comme flotteur et donc et en fait
ils flottent avec la coquille verticale
et avec leur tentacule ils marchent sur
le fond de l'océan et moi je trouvais ça
intéressant comme façon de représenter
la biologie des Orthocères voilà donc
cet épisode 2 euh ça a été quand même
voilà passer les banalités d'usage
concernant l'évolution des invertébrés
euh cet épisode 2 a été plutôt une une
bonne surprise et pareil la modélisation
est quand même pas dégueu du tout ceci
dit sur cet épisode 2 évidemment on m'a
fait remarquer que le
dclleosteus est vendu comme faisant 9 mè
et non pas les 5 m que la littérature
plus récente euh nous nous a proposé
donc on est reparti sur le bon vieux
d'un cléostéus de 9 m
euh qui qui qui est en fait une mesure
si vous ne savez pas l'histoire le
dclleéostéus de 9 m c'est une idée qui a
été sortie du cul ça vient de nulle part
euh et quand on fait réellement des des
vrais protocoles de mesure sur les
poissons modernes pour voir comment le
crâne parce que évidemment t us on en a
que le crâne mais quand on regarde les
poissons modernes pour voir comment le
crâne et à quel point l'échelle du crâne
permet de reconstituer la taille du
poisson entier ou bien d'autres éléments
squelétiques hein bah on se rend compte
que dcleosteus faisait beaucoup moins
que ça faisait 5 6 m maximum donc là on
est reparti sur le dcleosteus de 9 m ce
qui veut dire que du coup virgule animal
que j'avais fait dans débunkag et
pénitence virgule animal abattu euh la
série
Netflix la vie sur notre planète on en
arrive à l'épisode 3 alors l'épisode 3
on passe c'est la sortie des EAU donc on
passe beaucoup beaucoup de temps sur les
insectes et sur les amphibiens modernes
assez peu finalement d'images de la
sortie des EAU elles-même à part à un
moment il y a un dinust qui se fait
bouffer par un qui se fait bouffer par
un amphibien alors eux ils appellent ça
un amphibien mais ils appellent ça un
amphibien anracosor donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle les reptiliomorphes c'est les
amphibiens qui sont en phase de
transition vers un mode de vie plus
reptilien donc il sont un peu plus
adaptés à la vie sur terre ça ça se voit
parce qu'en fait on voyait déjà dans la
bandeannonce c'était celui que j'avais
appelé l'hynocéis ils ont pas confirmé
que c'était l'hynocélis mais c'est c'est
un reptiliomor c'est-à-dire que c'est
des amphibiens mais qui ont les yeux sur
les côtés donc c'est des amphibiens qui
ne vivent qui ne vivent déjà plus dans
l'eau puisqu'ils n'ont plus les yeux sur
le dessus du
crâne mais leur biologie était encore
relativement
hibienne donc on passe un tout petit peu
de temps là-dessus euh avec tout le
finalisme tout le finalisme d'usage
quiimplique de parler très très très
très vite de la sortie des os et des
premiers œufs à coquille à coquille
sèche hein donc les premiers œufs
amniotiques euh voilà c'est c'est là il
y a du finalisme il y a du le premier
animal qui a non il y a jamais eu de
premier animal ou même de première
individu qui a fait c ou fait ça c'est
ça c'est un mythe encore une fois c'est
un cliché de documentaire de montrer le
premier animal qui a fait si ou le
premier le premier humain qui s'est tenu
debout tout ça c'est c'est du cliché de
documentaire on parle l'évolution c'est
en population donc il y a un trait qui
apparaît dans une population ce trait se
répend dans la population ce trait se
développe ensuite dans la population
parce que évidemment vous imaginez bien
que l'œuf amniotique il est pas apparu
comme ça pouf d'un seul coup et hop d'un
se et fou c'est répandu dans la
population comme ça c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe c'est quelque chose qui
s'est construit graduellement sur la
longueur et on arrive à scutosaurus la
scène que j'attendais la scène sur le
Permien
supérieur le fameux celui celui où j'ai
tous les radars tous les
radars complètement allumé mode critique
overp là sur 11 PAM mode critique sur 11
les scutosaurus donc c'est
paréazor du Permien supérieur de Russie
donc on nous dit que ce sont des
scutosauruses euh on nous dit que ce
sont des scutosauruses et on nous les
accompagne regardez là ça c'est son
petit cul c'est un lyrosaure donc
lyrosaure et scutosaurus vivaient à deux
extrémités du monde
différentes c'est pas comme s'ils
avaient eu une chance de se croiser et
en plus vu la taille du lyrosaur c'est
pas un listrosaure du Permien ça c'est
cette taille- là c'est un dinosaure du
Trias donc euh ouais là je et la seule
raison pour laquelle ils l'ont mis là
c'est parce que dans l'épisode suivant
ils vont nous dire l'yrosaure est un
survivant mais enfin si vous voulez nous
faire nous vendre l'idée que l'yrosaure
est un survivant de la crise permiatrias
du coup donc un survivant de la grande
crise d'extinction permé intrias bah
faites un épisode entier sur l'yrosaurus
avant et après la crise mais là ils nous
mettent un lyrosaurus dans le décor
juste pour pouvoir dire eh regardez il
était là tu vois
et après ils en parlent pas du tout donc
il est juste dans le décor en fait et
donc pourquoi créer une incohérence
monstrueuse entre ce listrosaurus et ce
scutosaurus alors qu'on sait qu'il ne se
fréquentait pas quoi euh parce qu'il
vivait à comme je le disais à deux
extrémités opposé du monde mais il y a
il y a vraiment le passage que
j'attendais vraiment beaucoup et c'est
le passage avec le gorgonoptien alors
vous vous rappelez pendant que enfin si
vous avez vu la vidéo sur le trailer
j'avais dit ah ils ont mis un thérapside
ils ont mis un un thérapside carnivore
ça va être alors au début j'avais dit
gorgonopsien et puis après je me suis
dit non il ressemble pas à un
gorgonopsien parce que il lui ont collé
des poils généralement on colle pas des
poils au gorgonopsien on les colle
plutôt au thérocéphales et au cinodones
pour signaler leur appartenance à la
même lignée que celle des mammifères
euh c'est une connerie dans tous les cas
enfin on a aucune preuve de présence de
poil euh avant avant allez 40 millions
anné juste avant l'origine des tout
premiers trucs qu'on appellerait des
mammifères donc on est très très loin
des gorgonoptiens c'est juste ça on est
très très loin des gorgonopiens on est
très très loin des thérocéphales à la
limite les cnodontes les plus dérivé
pouvaient avoir des poils d'après les
preuves qu'on en a oui mettre des poils
quand on n pas de preuve de présence de
poil c'est legit comme move devant un
tribunal ça passe mais si vous prétendez
à de la justesse scientifique bah non du
coup ça marche pas euh si vous prétendez
à la justesse scientifique ça ne marche
pas et donc il y avait ce passage là où
on voit les dents de notre animal enfin
où on voit déjà les muscles vous voyez
ici les l'insertion des muscles sur la
tête vous voyez que les deux muscles
temporaux se joignent au milieu du crâne
et ça normalement ça marche pas chez les
gorgonoptiens parce que les
gorgonoptiens les muscles temporaux ils
s'arrêtent là euh juste sur les côtés
ils vont pas jusqu'au milieu du crâne ça
c'est une crête sagitale au milieu et la
crête sagitale c'est que chez les
thérocéphales et les don qu'on la voit
et le nombre de dents il est
complètement pété pour un gorgonopien
c'est pas du tout le nombre de voilà là
c'est parfait arrêt sur image absolument
parfait les gorgonoptiens ont cinq
incisives de chaque côté si vous êtes
inostr svia vous êtes l'unique exception
vous en avez quatre donc le gorgonoptien
le plus connu de Russie celui qui
normalement vit au côté de scutosaurus
donc celui qu'on est en train de vous
montrer là là il y en a tris de chaque
côté alors je sais pas si c'est un
problème de communication qu'il y a eu
entre les scientifiques et les
graphistes là mais clairement il y a eu
un problème parce que ça c'est pas du
tout une dentition d'ostrant svia il y a
beaucoup trop de dents aussi à l'arrière
des canines donc les ce ce qu'on
appellererait les molairires chez les
mammifères mais bon c'est pas encore des
molairires chez les gorgonopsiens donc
ça ça marche pas non plus le nombre de
la la dentition ne va pas du tout la
morphologie du crâne ne va pas du tout
et on nous vend ça comme un gorgonoptien
qui vivait à l'époque de scutosaurus que
vous voyez ici que vous voyez d'ailleurs
se déplacer en
troupeau ce qui alors scutosaurus on a
retrouvé beaucoup de squelettes ensemble
mais ça veut pas forcément dire qu'ils
vivaient ensemble ça veut dire qu'ils
sont morts ensemble voire même ça veut
juste dire que les cadavres ont été
rassemblés par une rivière en crue mais
bon à la limite je peux accepter que
scutosaurus se déplace en bande pourquoi
pas mais là la forme de ce crâne c'est
pas du tout la forme du crâne d'inostran
sevia quoi et et s'il y a scutosaurus
russe ça ne peut être que inosr sevia
c'est c'est forcément inostr sevia donc
là là là là il y a eu il y a eu boulette
là avec ce avec ça là avec ce
gorgonopien il y a eu boulette j'ajoute
en cours de montage alors c'est
peut-être une erreur qui n'est que dans
la version originale mais pas dans la
version française et on est honnêtement
à la frontière du pinaillage mais dans
le la version originale le gorgonopsien
est désigné comme étant un gorgonops
donc il l'appelle pas hostran sevia ils
appellent ça un gorgonopside sauf que
comme on l'a déjà dit ça ne peut-être
que hostrevia étant donné qu'il est
accompagné de scutosaurus or
inostranevia n'est pas un gorgonopside
hostranevia appartient bel et bien à
l'ordre des gorgonopsiens mais pas à la
famille des gorgonopsides en terme
d'erreur taxonomique ça revient à
confondre un nominid donc comme par
exemple Scarlett Johanson avec n'importe
quel autre membre de l'ordre des
primates et c'est la scène que
j'attendais le plus parce que le le
voilà le gorgonopsen quoi le gorgonops
les mecs vous avez vous avez rater le
Gorgon il est tellement mal
fait c'est juste pour vous rappeler le
trailer pourir rappeler l'analyse du
trailer il est tellement mal fait que je
m'étais mis à espérer que ce soit un
véusodon c'est-à-dire un syynodonte je
sa pas si vous vous rappelez mais
j'avais dit ah oui on voit on voit que
les muscles se joignent au milieu donc
il a une crête sagittale le nombre
incisive et réduit il y a beaucoup de
dents à l'arrière des des canines
peut-être que c'est un cyodonte
peut-être que et là je les prends dans
mes bras et je les embrasse s'ils ont
fait ça peut-être que c'est un vétusodon
c'est ENF de l'originalité bah non bah
non on vous remet inostran sevia et en
plus on le
rate au moins il a pas de moustache et
puis surtout il y a la scène de chasse
qui suit juste après la scène de chasse
c'est ce qui illustre parfaitement ce
que je disais tout à l'heure à propos du
ils avaient une idée cool mais ils y ont
pas réfléchi ils voulaient une scène de
chasse entre gorgonopien et scutosaurus
sauf que gorgonopien il fait 500 kg
maximum plutôt proche de 300 à mon avis
mais 500 kg maximum scutosaurus il fait
une tonne mais il voulait une scène de
chasse où le gorgonopsien chope le
scutosaurus alors scutosaurus qui est un
animal blindé hein il y a y a une
carapace d'ostéoderme donc il faut qu'il
le retourne pour pouvoir le tuer donc
faut que c il faut que cet animal de 500
kg retourne un animal d'une tonne animal
d'une tonne qui a en plus les bras
fléchis donc il a une posture semi semi
rampante enfin quasiment rampante et qui
donc et qui en plus est cours sur patte
donc il est très près du sol cette scène
c'est juste on avait une idée cool et on
emmerde la physique parce que du coup
bah le Gorgon obtien la façon dont il
retourne le scutosaurus c'est juste la
gravité on l'emmerde et le moment où il
tue le le scutosaurus et là je vous le
mets parce que là voyez il va lui mettre
un grand coup de dents de sabre pour
pouvoir tuer le scutosaurus dans la
jugulaire évidemment parce que bref
regardez et P oh Marie du orchamp et
pourquoi magie du orchamp bah parce que
le modèle leur modèle de gorgonopsien
n'est pas capable d'ouvrir la gueule
suffisamment grand pour pouvoir mordre
la le coup de ce scutosaurus qui a un
coup de rugby Man et c'est juste bah
pourquoi vous l'avez fait du coup
pourquoi vous avez montré ça comme ça
vous ariez plus d'ailleurs je retire ce
que j'ai dit il y a des
moustaches en plus Mme même pas ça je
retire ce que j'ai dit il y a des
moustaches en
plus c'est pas comme si on avait sorti
ça pas comme si depuis 2016 on sortait
des article à répétition pour dire
qu'ils avaient pas de
moustache bref donc voyez ils ont pas
ils ont pas réfléchi ils avaient une
idée cool et ils ont vu que ça marchait
pas mais ils l'ont fait quand même et et
ça je trouve ça dommage je trouve
vraiment vraiment vraiment ça dommage
parce que bah il ils avaient
misopportunités en fait de se rendre
compte que ouais non mais ça marche pas
c'est pas comme ça qui chassait ce Tru
quoi c'est évident que c'est pas comme
ça qu' chassait il devait pas s'en
prendre au scutosaurus adulte je veux
dire c'est comme c'est comme des lions
attaquant un éléphant adulte quoi et
encore les lions qui attaqu les
éléphants adultes les attaquent pas tout
seul ou alors ils sont morts voilà il
vont ils vont crever ils sont désespérés
ils attaquent un éléphant adulte tout
seul là vous avez un lion tout seul qui
attaque un éléphant adulte parce qu'il
est désespéré et puis il est mort quoi
ce ce lion vous êtes pas obligé de faire
gagner le prédateur non plus par exemple
mais bref scutosaurus voilà il est
blindé il est géant c'est bon une fois
adulte il est en sécurité bon étant un
reptile scutosaurus devait pas avoir de
de soins parentaux hyper développés donc
on aurait pu partir là-dessus tu vois
avec un juvénil qui se promènerait tout
seul et puis PAM le champ per inocente
Sévia lui tombe dessus donc là ouais ça
illustre assez bien le côté on avait une
idée cool et on l'a poussé on a poussé
le potard jusqu'au bout mais même en
voyant que ça marchait pas on l'a garder
quand même épisode 4 maintenant bah on
est après la crise d'extinction de masse
donc du coup il ne nous montre pas
enfinci il nous montre un peu la crise
d'extinction de masse mais pas tant que
ça mais du coup voilà l'avant après on
n'y a pas le droit et ça ça aurait été
ça aurait été bien du coup de garder bah
le une belle montrer la diversité qu'il
y avait avant la crise montrer la
diversité qu'il y avait après la crise
mais là du coup non on démarre
directement après la crise et on démarre
avec un lyrosaurus tout seul alors ça
s'il y a bien un truc qu'on savait à
propos de qu'on sait à propos de
l'yrosaurus c'est qu'un un lyrosaurus
tout
seul ça n'existe pas vraiment ça veut
pas dire que les listrosaurus se
déplçaient en troupeau ça c'est pas vrai
mais par contre ils étaient jamais
c'était pas des troupeaux mais c'était
si vous voulez c'était de ils étaient
ensemble quoi ils étaient là tous au
même endroit mais l'yrosaurus tout seul
ça on en trouve
jamais donc commencer par un lyrosaurus
tout seul bah c'est parce qu'on veut
montrer l'idée que maintenant il y a eu
l'extinction de masse et que du coup il
y a plus de diversité mais ça aurait été
peut-être plus pertinent de montrer
avant diversité avant après donc
finalement montrer ce qu'il y avait dans
l'épisode d'avant dans cet épisode là
avec une toute une scène montrant le
listrosaurus avant l'extinction après
l'extinction et en plus en nous montrant
un un petit lyrosaurus un lyrosaurus de
petite taille dans l'épisode précédent
bah ils sont passés à côté d'un des
effets majeurs de la crise permiantrias
qui est le rétrécissement des
listrosaurus pour économiser la
nourriture enfin ils auraient pu dire ça
au moins pour économiser la nourriture
même si c'est pas que ça la raison de
l'effet Liliput mais ils auraient pu
montrer ça du coup mais bon du coup non
il nous montre un hisrosaurus tout seul
tout ça pour au final le faire rejoindre
ses potes ils sont là donc on nous
montre un lrosaurus tout seul et il y a
plus de nourriture et il est désespéré
mais en fait
non bon B ça va du coup ouais juste pour
revenir sur la modélisation du
listrosaurus il est très très beau voilà
je je l'avais déjà dit dans le trailer
mais la peau veruqueuse le bec est
exactement au bon endroit les
proportions sont bonnes la forme de la
tête est bonne tout est nickel la PO sur
des jambes tout est nickel sur ce
lyrosaurus voilà ça c'est faut que ce
soit dit faut que ce soit dit et je le
redis ce ce listrosaurus c'est un plus
un quand même voilà il y a quand même il
y a quand même ça qui marche bien on
nous insère quelques petites
incohérences dans cet épisode notamment
bah vous voyez les listrosaurus et le
truc qui va chasser nos listrosaurus oh
ce bébé listrosaurus il était trop
mignon leslistrosaurus vont se faire
chasser par un
eritthrosucus sauf que eritthrosucus de
de la même m manière que scutosaurus et
et et lyrosaurus n'ont pas pu se croiser
parce qu'ils étaient aux antipodes l'un
de l'autre eritrosucus et listrosaurus
se sont jamais croisés parce que il y a
quelques millions d'années entre les
deux donc là il y a il y a il y a un
anachronisme en fait et donc c'est c'est
pour nous illustrer que maintenant les
reptiles et les Synapsides vont être en
concurrence donc il va y avoir les deux
grandes lignées ce qu'on nous explique
c'est qu'il y a les deux grandes lignées
he les reptiles et cell qui donnera la
naissance son mammifèr ils utilisent
jamais le mynapside ou thrapside ils
utilisent la lignée des mammifères et
donc maintenant la lignée des mammifères
et la lignée des reptiles vont se mener
une une lutte sans merci à partir du
début du Mésozoïque pour la domination
des écosystèmes terrestres et même marin
en réalité
mais il commencer par illustrer ça en
nous montrant un lyrosaure qui se fait
bouffer par un reptile bah
protterosucus il y avait proteroszucus
qui est à peine enfin qui qui a
un peu plus petit que que
eritrosucus il est un peu plus bizarre
parce que son nez est un peu plus déjà
lui son nez il penche vers le bas là
mais proterosucus il penche vraiment
vers le bas mais voilà il il y avait
proterosucus et d'ailleurs euh sur la
terre des monstres disparus donc
l'équivalent BBC de enfin l'équivalent
de sur la terre des dinosaures mais qui
nous montre ce qu'il y a avant les
dinosaures donc sur la terre des
monstres disparus avait mon un
protterosucus qui attaquait un
lyrosaurus mais en l'occurrence il
l'attaquait en ces termes c'est-à-dire
dans l'eau le lyrosaurus croisé une
rivière et là il se faisait attraper par
un protterosucus et ça et ça marchait et
ça marchait très bien alors je comprends
qu'ils ai pas voulu reproduire
exactement la même scène mais en même
temps on est après une crise
d'extinction de masse donc oui la
biodiversité elle est pas ouf donc ça va
être compliqué de montrer autre chose
que ce qu'il y avait à l'époque donc
c'est dommage c'est dommage et puis un
peu plus plus loin on nous parle d'un
plaiosaure en nous montrant un pliosaure
aussi donc il y a des il y a des choses
un peu un peu cheloues et c'est dans cet
épisode là qu'on a le les gnous qui sont
absolument inconscients du danger qui
les guettte c'est c'est dans cet
épisodeci épisode 5 maintenant nous
sommes au temps des dinosaures et là on
va passer beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup du
film à nous parler des plantes à fleurs
et de la coévolution avec les insectes
donc c'est ce que je disais quand on
nous rappelle que il y a pas que les
dinosaures dans la vie là ça c'est un
des épisodes typiquement comme ça
l'épisode 5 c'est un des meilleurs
épisodes pour moi je pense parce que
mais regardez la beauté de ce
denonicus regardez la beauté de ce
denonicus là le bébé et l'adulte ils ont
ils ont une vie dans le regard c'est
même pas que la beauté graphique ou la
modélisation des plumes ils ont une vie
dans le regard on a vraiment
l'impression regard qu'il y a une
complicité entre la maman et le petit
c'est quand même assez fou ça ça leur
donne une vraiment une une Pat quoi ça
donne vraiment quelque chose quoi de
quelque chose de très bien il a un peu
cette texture en pot de poulet là que
j'aime beaucoup aussi le fait qu'ils ai
des lèvres et que du coup on ne voit pas
les dents bah ça ça rajoute un peu à
leur humanité entre guillemets
c'est-à-dire que ça les rend un peu plus
ça les rend ça leur enlève ce côté un
peu monstrueux quand on laisse les dents
sorties ça leur rajoute un petit côté
humain presque du coup surtout quand on
le voit de face là on a on a moins la
perspective du museau et du coup ça ça
leur donne un petit côté humain donc
évidemment les denonicus qu'on nous
montre ensuite en train de chasser en
meut dans une scène complètement je suis
je vais employer les mots de de Sophie
he de Miss plume pour ça dans une scène
complètement
stupide dans une scène complètement
stupide parce qu'en fait on nous dit il
chasse en meut ce qu'on sait déjà être
faux hein ce n'est pas vrai l'idée de la
chasse en meut chez denonicus ça vient
d'un fossile où on a retrouver des
macabés désarticulés de denonicus avec
un Macabé désarticulés d'adrosaur
euh ce sont des macabés désarticulés
retrouvés ensemble donc pour autant
qu'on sache ils auraient pu être amenés
là par une rivière qui a Charié tous les
macabés c'est pas une preuve de chasse
en meut du tout voilà donc c'est de là
que ça vient denonicus qui chasse en
meut et donc c'est c'est voilà ça vaut
ce que ça vaut c'est c'est bof donc là
on nous dit qu'il chasse en meut donc ce
qui est déjà en soi pas forcément vrai
on nous montre des soins parentauus qui
récemment avec des analyses isotopiques
des dents de juvéniles d'adultes aussi a
été remis en question hein ils ont
montré que la la la chimie dentaire des
adultes et celle des enfants étai
différent ce qui veut dire qu'ils
avaient un régime alimentaire différent
ce qui veut dire que les adultes ne
nourrissaient pas les petits donc pas de
soins parentaux apparemment donc on nous
montre des soins parentaux on nous
montre des denonicus en train de chasser
en meut et surtout quand il chasse en
meute j'en viens à la chasse stupide il
il court après le truc tous ensemble et
ça c'est débile c'est c'est ça sert à
rien chasser en meut si vous courez tous
après le truc
tout tous ensemble je veux dire faites
une embuscade voilà essayez de le
coincer faites une battue faites des
trucs que font les animaux qui chassent
réellement en meut courez pas après
surtout que le machin en plus c'est
tellement con que une fois de plus on
est dans le même cas que inostran sevia
c'est ça ne marche tellement pas qu'ils
ne se sont qu'ils sont obligé de faire
plier les lois de la physique à leur
scénario c'està-dire que lui là il a des
jambes vachement plus grande que les
denonicus si vous voulez ils sont
obligés de tricher avec la physique de
leur scène pour que ce Macha là ne court
pas un milliard de fois plus vite que
que eux là enfin que leornitomimosor du
coup met pas une distance de fou au
denonicus parce que le machin il a des
jambes ses jambes sont aussi longues que
le denonicus est haut c'estàd que il
leur met une tracé mais en vrai donc ils
sont obligés de jouer avec la physique
de richicher avec la physique pour pas
que ce Macha là leur mette une distance
d'avance pour que la scène puisse avoir
lieu et pareil ils avaient une idée cool
en tête et quand ils ont vu que ça
marchait pas ils ont dit bah tant pis la
physique voilà et ça c'est dommage mais
ça reste quand même un de mes épisodes
préférés pour la scène avec les T-Rex
parce qu'il y a quand même la scène avec
les T-Rex la petite parade nuptiale de
la fin donc on nous fait un suspense
avec un T-Rex qui rencontre un autre
T-Rex et oh mon dieu est-ce qu'ils vont
se battre et tout et non en fait c'est
une femelle et lui c'est un mâle donc
vous noterez d'ailleurs que la femelle
est marron et que le mâle a la tête
rouge vous verrez c'est important dans
l'épisode suivant et donc ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant bah c'est la la façon dont
se déroule la parade nuptiale est
absolument parfaite c'est exactement de
cette façonl qu'on doit reconstruire une
parade nuptiale de T-Rex étant donner ce
qu' sait de leur fossil et là je vais
mettre un marqueur ici parce que ça
c'est beau ça c'est beau c'est beau donc
qu'est-ce qu'on sait de T-Rex T-Rex a
les les EAU nazau ici là sur le nez les
EOS sont fusionnées et forment une crête
et et ça ne sert pas à l'évidence à
quelque chose c'est d'autant plus c'est
à une époque on aurait pu dire alors ça
renforce la crête nasale contre la
pression exercée par la mâchoire quand
elle mort parce que évidemment Trex a
une mâchoire surpuissante qui permet de
broyer les eau et cette énergie quand il
mort elle se dirige vers les zones azo
vers le sommet du crâne et donc on
aurait pu dire bah oui les zones azo
sont fusionnées pour permettre au crâne
de résister quand il morent on aurait pu
dire ça mais maintenant on sait que même
les tyranosauroïdes qui n'avaient pas
une morsure aussi puissante que T-Rex
avaient aussi les zonazo fusionné
certains portant même des crêtes très
très hautes donc en fait depuis le
départ les tyranosauroïdes ont les EAU
naso fusionné et porte des des organes
finalement de de de démonstration des
des organes qui servent à montrer
quelque chose et ce quelque chose bah là
voilà si vous cherchez à montrer une
parade nuptiale de Trex évidemment qu'il
faut interpréter ce quelque chose comme
étant de l'ordre de la parade sexuelle
évidemment c'est la solution évidente
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait bah le Mâ est
rouge la femelle enfin le malâ a la tête
rouge et surtout cette crête nasale la
femelle a la tête brune et le mâle
s'incline devant la femelle pour lui
montrer sa crête nasale toute rouge
voilà ça c'est normal ça c'est un
comportement normal un comportement
logique inféré à partir de ce qu'on sait
des fossile c'est pas la peine de me
demander ce que je pense de ces plumules
de merde à l'arrière de sa tête je m'en
tape on n a pas de reste
fossile ça là le crâne on en a du
fossile on sait qu'il a une crête on en
fait quelque chose pas comme
préhistorique planète qui n'en fait rien
du tout voilà là on en fait quelque
chose et on en fait quelque chose de
logique il a une crête nasale il
s'incline devant la femelle pour la lui
montrer ça fait en plus ça fait une
position de soumission et ça sachant que
les femelles étaient plus grosses que
les mâles chez T-Rex une fois de plus le
T-Rex qui se montre en humilité devant
la femelle ça a du sens parce que encore
une fois ce qu'on sait ou croit savoir
de T-Rex c'est que les femelles étaient
plus grosses que les mâles les mâles
prennent un risque en allant chatouiller
les femelles avec leurs petits bras donc
ça c'est ça ça c'est beau ça c'est beau
de voir ça donc il font une parade
nuptiale où le mâle s'incline et la
femelle finit par s'incliner avec lui
regardez cette belle crête nasale
magnifique rouge rouge vif gonflé de
sang injecté de testostérone d'un Mâ qui
cherche à se reproduire VO regardez la
qualité de cette modélisation mesdames
et messieurs ça c'est beau c'est beau ce
que je vois là c'est beau regardez cette
belle inclinaison et donc quand la
femelle a fini par accepter le malâ qu
qui est fait là il lui montre sa gorge
là il lui montre sa gorge et c'est là
que c'est beau préhistorique planète
regarde et apprends préhistorique
planète dans préhistorique planète le
malâ il arrive il montre direct gorge à
la femelle qui est plus grosse que lui
et qui a probablement la dalle ben
évidemment qu'il va
crever là le malâ arrive montre sa crête
en premier attend que la femelle montre
des signes d'acceptation et ensuite il
lui montre sa gorge et là ça a du sens
parce que justement il lui montre la
partie la plus vulnérable et le
narrateur le dit le narrateur dit
maintenant le mal lui montre sa partie
la plus vulnérable en signe de
confiance tu as accepté mon offre de te
reproduire je te montre que j'ai compris
en faisant quoi en te montrant ma gorge
et en te disant tu vois là si j'avais
pas compris les signaux que tu
m'envoyais bah je te montrerais pas ma
partie je te montrerai pas ce qui
exactement ce qu'il faut pour que tu me
tues et ça c'est beau ça c'est beau
voilà et à la fin qu'est-ce qu'ils font
ils se touch le
museau voilà il se touche il se tripote
mais pas n'importe où le museau parce
qu'on sait que les T-Rex ils étaient
très sensibles du museau c'était par le
museau qu'il communiquait encore une
fois ça se voit sur les fossiles des
canaux nerveux qui vont dans le museau
il y en a plein il en a plein c'est
gorgé de canon nerveux là-dedans c'est
plein de morsures regardez comme c'est
cabossé là c'est beau c'est cabossé ça
c'est un T-Rex qu' a vécu ça c'est pas
c'est pas un T-Rex fraîchement sorti de
la de l'usine comme on voyait dans
historique planète ça c'est un museau de
T-Rex qui a vécu c'est cabossé il y a eu
des morsures là-dessus parce que c'est
comme ça qu'il communiquait parce qu'on
le et on le sait et c'est beau et c'est
beau j'arrêterai pas de le répéter c'est
beau donc voilà et ça ça c'est mon
épisode préféré ça j'aime j'aime j'aime
et je valide je suis Julien Benoît et je
valide c'est pas de la merde ça mesdames
et messieurs ça c'est du
bon ah non mais je deviens émotif mais
mais faut le dire faut le dire faut le
dire parce que dans les éisode suivant
hein l'épisode 6 bah là voahà bah le le
T-Rex on nous vend un Trex femelle en
train d'élever ses deux petit de de leur
apprendre à chasser le Trex femelle il a
quoi il a la tête rouge perdu perdu donc
incohérence avec l'épisode précédent
dans l'épisode suivant on nous monre on
nous montre un pliosaur alors que c'est
le jour cette histoire là dans le
l'épisode suivant est censé se passer le
jour de la chute de la météorite bon bah
les os ils étaient déjà éteints ils
étaient canés depuis longtemps mais on
nous montre quoi un pliosaure alors on
essaie de nous le faire passer pour un
mosasur on essaie on essaye mais ça
enfin le crâne c'est pas le même entre
un mosasaur et un pliosaure donc c'est
bon bah c'est un mauvais modèle de
mosasaur au mieux c'est un très très
très mauvais modèle de mosasaur tout au
mieux mais en tout cas ce qu'on nous
montre c'est un pliosaure et les pliosur
à la toute fin du Crétacé ils sont déjà
éteints et puis on nous montre un
anchyornis alors l'ankorn vous le voyez
il est bon il est un peu trop clair
comparé à ce qu'on sait de la couleur du
plumage de l'ankyornis puisque
l'ankyornis c'est quand même le premier
dinosaure pour qui on a été capable de
reconstruire la couleur des plumes grâce
au mélanosomees préservés dans ces
plumes des magnifique fossil chinois qui
conserve des mélanosomes donc ça euh les
couleurs à la limite bon il est il est
il est gris clair au lieu d'être noir
noir profond à la limite mais le le le
pattern sur les ailes c'est à peu près
ça le petit Toupé rouge c'est à peu près
ça mais c'est pas le la physique de
l'ankquyornis c'est que
l'ankquyornis c'est un animal qu'on voit
vivre dans la forêt et là d'un seul coup
il se fait chasser par cette bestiolle
là don bah dont j'ai même pas compris le
nom parce que Morgan Freeman il a du mal
à le prononcer donc il se fait chasser
par un gros carnivore et là au lieu de
faire ce qu'un orchynist normal aurait
dû faire c'est-à-dire grimper dans un
arbre direct bah encore une fois les
réalisateurs ou les scénaristes je je
sais pas ils avaient une idée en tête
eux ils voulaient que l'ankyornis se
jette du haut de la falaise voilà il
voulaaiit que l'ankyornis se jette du
haut de la falaise comme
ça et donc ils nous ont fait une scène
de chasse où au lieu de d'avoir
l'ankyorn ce petit animal dont on sait
qu'il était arboricole et qui
aurait nécessairement fui dans les
arbres en voyant arriver un prédateur il
aurait grimpé dans l'AR il l'aurait
regardé dans e il aurait fait tu as
l'air con maintenant non ils ont fait
ORNIS qui court jusqu'à la falaise d'à
côté et là qu'est-ce qu'il fait il saute
il saute cet anyornis alors je rappelle
que sauter de cette altitude là pour un
animal planeur qui n'a aucune adaptation
au vol battu bah en fait les adaptation
en vol battu elles vont de paire avec
des adaptations à l'atterrissage quand
vous êtes quand vous êtes un planeur ça
va vous faites pas des longues distance
mais là le temps que l'ankyornis il
atteigne les arbres en bas il sera c 2
le gars il sera à Mac 2 la réception va
être dure hein enornis il a pas de
sainsrome dans le bassin donc les eaux
du bassin sont pas fusionné il a pas de
tibiotars et il a pas de tarsoméatars
dans les pâtes pour amortir le choc il a
zéro adaptation pour atterrir lors qui
horniss donc là il va arriver à MC 2
dans les arbres en bas le plus dur sera
la chute hein et en plus
l'anquornis il a pas il a pas de bréché
donc ses muscles pectoraux là les
muscles qui servent à tenir les ailes
comme ça
là à tenir les ailes ouvertes et à
résister contre la pression de l'air bah
c'est des muscles qui sont très très
faibles parce qu'il a pas de lame
osseuse au niveau pour tenir les les
muscles pectoraux surdéveloppés des des
oiseaux les blancs de
poulet et donc donc donc donc bah là il
a des muscles là là il est parti pour
planer pendant je sais pas combien de
temps alors qu'il en est pas capable
c'est au bout d'un moment c'est ses
muscles vont lâcher en fait physiquement
ça va péter quoi et c'est pour ça les
les les planeurs ils vont d'arbre en
arbre ils vont pas d'une falaise
jusqu'en bas ça c'est donc ça c'est
juste complètement impossible ce qui
fait l' quiorniss et encore une fois ça
part d'une idée cool et quand on et et
et une fois m de je veux dire une fois
confronté à cette situation là où vous
avez anchyornis qui constate qu'il y a
un prédateur qui le regarde bah oui la
solution naturelle c'est évidemment dans
l'arbre
zo sachant qu'il a toutes les
adaptations pour y aller dans l'arbre en
quiorniss donc c'est c'est c'est
vraiment
le c'est c'est c'est vraiment une scène
qui qui marche pas ça ne marche pas
alors ça donne des images cool mais ça
ne marche pas on a ensuite l'extinction
he la la grande extinction Crétacé
tertière alors non ça en fait ça
commence par l'extinction Crétacé
tertière je vous l'ai dit he que ça
faisait des alleretours louv dingue et
donc dans cette extinction Crétacé
tercière comme je vous l'ai expliqué
elle est très bien représ vous voyez le
carnage est évident c'est une très très
bonne modélisation de l'extinction
Crétacé tarcière il y a aucun problème
ou KPG si vous préférez l'appeler comme
ça le problème le problème c'est qu'ils
ne savent pas quoi dire et du coup ils
se mettent à nous expliquer ah voilà le
pliosaur le voilà le pliosaure du cré
assz supérieur le problème c'est qu'il
se metent à nous expliquer que B et là
il y a même une baleine cameo baleine
bon elle est morte mais co baleine quand
même ils se mettent à nous expliquer en
fait pourquoi les espèces ont survécu
donc il y a les cafardes qui ont survécu
et puis il y a les insectes alors les
insectes ils ont une coquille dure et
puis les animaux qui vivent dans des
terriers ils ont survécu et puis les
amphibiens ils ont survécu alors si
quelqu'un sait pourquoi les amphibiens
ou comment les amphibiens ont survécu à
la crise crétass et tertière faut
publier dans Nature tout de suite parce
que là l'explication qui vous sortte ça
n'a aucun sens c'est les amphibiens
c'est le grand mystère de la crise
crétaciée tertièire hein c'est comment
des machins qui aujourd'hui crève au
moindre changement de pH de la flotte
dans laquelle ils vivent comment ça ça a
survécu à la crise crétaassé tertière on
n sait rien on n sait absolument rien
donc il nous inventent des explications
au pif et alors ils nous disent à la fin
les oiseaux ont résisté parce qu'ils
pondent des œufs et alors ça nous
disent-il en plus en nous montrant des
œufs d'meux donc même pas des dinosaures
là c'est des émeux c'est complètement
des ameux donc ouais il savait pas quoi
dire encore une fois il voulait montrer
la crise crétacée tercière mais il
savait pas quoi dire dessus donc on a
brodé on a brodé et je suis très triste
cet épisode 6 je suis très triste parce
qu'à la fin on nous montre le cameéo
d'un Esper ornice je crois qu'il est là
il était quelque part par là je crois
voilà il y a le CÉO d'un Esper hornice
je crois qu'ils ont fait toute une scène
avec l'Esper hornis qui l'ont coupé au
montage ou alors c'est un corps Morant
vraiment chelou mais ça ça ressemble à
un esert hornis et le pauvre espert
hornis il a été coupé au montage je sais
pas s'il y a des gens qui sont
suffisamment fanatiques pour aller
vérifier si mais je crois qu'on avait un
Esper hornis et il a été coupé au
montage et puis on arrive aux épisodes 7
et 8 donc les épisodes C et8 où hélas le
le nombre de plans où on inclut des
espèces éteintes ça ça se compte sur le
doigt d'une main c'est ça se compte en
ça se compte en secondes à ce niveau-là
donc on voitp onte mayacetus un bronter
dans l'épisode 8 on voit un mammouth le
lion des cavernes et basta il y a
peut-être un il y a peut-être un
Smilodon qui se planque quelque part
dans le tas il y a des
humains évidemment mais bon les humains
ça ça compte pas vraiment comme espèce
éteinte donc ouais épisode 7 et 8 c'est
là où on commence vraiment à s'ennuyer
c'est là où la modilisation commence à
pêcher mayacu c'est dégueulasse mais
vraiment
dégueulasse il se fait chasser par un
autodus voilà comme je disais c'est
mégalodon sans sans être mégalodon voilà
on met un autodus mais pas mégalodon
c'est un autre c'est une autre espèce
d'utodus mais donc on nous monte
mayacetus on ne nous montre pas la
raison pour laquelle mayacetus porte son
nom à savoir mayacetus qui est en train
en train de mettre bas à la façon des
mammifères terrestres et non pas à la
façon des des cétacer les les deux
derniers épisodes c'est des
documentaires animaliers il y a vraiment
plus rien au niveau des espèces éteintes
donc j'ai très très peu de choses à dire
je veux juste vous montrer la scène qui
m'a le plus marqué qui à mon avis sera
la raison pour pour laquelle la vie sur
notre planète deviendra une série
iconique c'est le Smilodon qui ne sait
pas quoi face à des glyptodonte
armé armuré jusqu'aux
dents il leur grime dessus il fait
joujou il gratouille il fait le chat en
fait c'est un smilodont qui qui fait le
chat sur les glyptodontes quoi et qui
sait pas quoi de ces glyptodontes
et du coup il se couche dessus puis il
attend et moi j'ai trouvé ça ilarant
comme scène donc il y avait quand même
du bon dans ces épisodes là mais
globalement l'épisode 7 et 8 ouais c'est
c'est du reportage
animalier il y a quasiment plus rien en
terme de paléontologie dans l'épisode
78 voilà c'était la petit passage en
revue de des épisodes un par un de la
vie sur notre planète je vous dis à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne
salut